or ask to use the distributive property  to expand this expression so let me get  my little scratch pad out so this is the  same question right over here so we're  gonna multiply six times this entire  quantity so let me just rewrite it this  is six times negative 4w negative 4w  plus one half plus one half so we're  going to distribute the six so this is  going to be six times negative 4w times  six plus six times one half so this is  going to be six times let me just write  it this way six times negative 4w  negative 4w plus plus 6 times 6 times  1/2 and this is going to be equal to 6  times negative 4w is negative 24 W and  then 6 times one half is three so we get  negative 24 W plus three so let me write  that down  negative 24 W plus three and let's check  our answer